man kann vieles in home office machen
genauso wie im büro
aber wir sind regina ist ein
produktionsbetrieb und wir haben 1200
mitarbeiter und davon sind nur 35 in der
verwaltung und die und die anderen sind
in der produktion also eine näherin die
muss an der maschine waren sitzen und
die gibt die man das was sie nicht wird
weitergereicht und so weiter und das ist
im home-office theoretisch nicht möglich
dann der stricker der die stoffe strecke
sind auch maschinen die müssen in die
ausrüstung weiter der verbraucher also
dass sie ist da nicht möglich aber wenn
ich dann in die verwaltung gehen ist es
auch bei uns in der verwaltung nicht
möglich weil wir so kurze wege haben wir
sitzen ja alle zusammen und wenn ich bin
ich eine entscheidung treffe oder einen
mitarbeiter eine frage hat dann kommt er
zu mir und es muss sofort entschieden
werden so haben wir ja auch als erste
sozusagen einen einen ganzen betrieb der
überhaupt nichts mit maske zu tun hat
innerhalb von wenigen tagen durch diese
schnelligkeit umgestellt in der
fertigung auf masten und das sind
vorteile von denen wir heute leben wir
haben keine aufträge für morgen sondern
wir kriegen täglich die aufträge und
müssen uns darauf einstellen und da
brauche ich alle meine mitarbeiter die
zusammen die zusammen die probleme die
kleinen probleme lösen damit wir kein
großes haben wenn jetzt ein bewerber zu
ihnen kämen abteilungsleiter in der
verwaltung und sagen würde er möchte
gern ein drittel ungefähr im home office
arbeiten hätten sie dafür verständnis
für sie nein ich habe volles verständnis
dass er es will aber ich könnte ihnen
den job nicht geben weil das wäre
unmöglich bei uns weil wir brauchen die
leute konstant auch wenn ich unterwegs
bin auf irgend einer reise dann kriege
ich eine mitteilung wann ich wieder da
bin will der mit weil er mich vor ort
braucht und wir brauchen uns gegenseitig
und müssen gegenseitig ganz schnell das
was auf uns zukommt lösen und
entscheiden mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren